what does it mean to live an infinite
life
clearly our lives are finite we're born
we die we come we go
but life is infinite the game of life
will continue with us or without us
which means every single one of us has a
choice
we don't get to choose the nature of the
game life is infinite
we don't even get to choose if we want
to play in the game or night once you're
born
you're in it
we get one do you want to play
with a finite mindset or do you want to
play with an infinite mindset
to play with a finite mindset means
waking up every day and say i'm going to
be the best i'm going to be better than
everybody else
i'm going to accumulate more power more
responsibility
more money whatever it is whatever
whatever your metric is
i'm gonna i'm gonna get more than
anybody else me
and when you die you take none of it
with you
or we can choose to live our lives with
an infinite mindset
which means i'm going to leave this
world the school
in better shape than i found it it means
i'm going to devote my life to see that
those around me rise
and we know that we're living with an
infinite mindset because our obsession
is seeing that we have an impact on the
lives of the people around us
we've all had teachers and some of you
are those teachers we're
20 or 30 years from now i can go to one
of your students and say you're a
remarkable human being you've
accomplished so much in your life
how did you become the person you are
today and they will tell me your name
we all remember the teacher who believed
in us we all remember the teacher who
had our backs we all remember the
teachers saw something in us that nobody
else saw we've forgotten all the others
but we remember those couple and that's
what it means to live with an infinite
mindset it means we divert ourselves to
that
mindset for everyone in our lives that
other teachers will say that about us
other principles will say that about us
other students will say that about us
our friends will say that about us i
am who i am today because of you and i
will commit to live the same life that
you taught me how to live
and you will literally live on beyond
your own lifestyle your own lifetime
that when you're gone others will carry
your work
for you this is what it means to live an
infinite life and it is just
a choice
you